if we're traveling out there
Interstellar travel or um
doing some of the interesting things
we'll be talking about how much
of those ships would be occupied by AI
systems do you think
what would the
what would be the living organisms
occupying those ships
yeah it it's depressing to think about
AI in the search for life because
it has I mean I've been thinking about
this a lot over the last few weeks with
playing around with chat gbt3 like many
of us and being astonished with its
capabilities and you see that it that
our society
is undergoing a change that seems
significant in terms of the development
of artificial we've been promised this
revolution this Singularity for a long
time but it really seems to be stepping
up its uh its pace of development at
this point and so that's interesting
because as someone who looks freely in
life out there in the universe
um it sort of implies that our current
stage development is highly transitional
and that
you know you go back for the last four
and a half billion years the the planet
was done essentially if you go back uh
that's a few thousand years there was a
civilization but it wasn't really
producing any technical signatures and
then over the last maybe 100 years
there's been something that might be
detectable from afar
but we're approaching this cusp where we
might imagine it I mean we're thinking
of like maybe years and decades with AI
development typically when we talk about
this but as an astronomer I have to
think about much longer time scares of
centuries Millennia millions of years
and so if this
if this wave continues over that time
scale which is still the blink of an eye
on a cosmic time scale
that implies that
everything will be AI essentially out
there if this is a common behavior and
so that's intriguing because it sort of
implies that we are
uh special in in terms of Our Moment In
Time as a civilization
which it normally is
um
something we're averse to as astronomers
we we normally like this mediocrity
principle we're not special we're a
typical part of the universe sometimes
another cosmological principle but in a
temporal sense we may be in a unique
location and perhaps that is part of the
solution to the Fermi Paradox in fact
that if it is true that plants tend to
go through basically three phases dumb
life for the vast majority a brief
period of biological intelligence and
then an extended period of artificial
intelligence that they transition to
then we would be in a unique and special
moment in Galactic history that would be
of particular interest for any
anthropologists out there in the galaxy
right this would be the time that you
would want to study a civilization very
carefully you wouldn't want to interfere
with it you would just want to see how
it plays out kind of similar to the
ancestor simulations I sometimes talked
out with the simulation argument that
you are able to observe perhaps your own
Origins and study how the transformation
happens and so yeah that has for me
recently been destroying the filming
Paradox a bit on his head and this idea
of the the zoo hypothesis that we may be
monitored which has for a long time been
sort of
seen as a fringe idea even amongst the
seti community but
if we live in this truly transitional
period it adds a lot of impetus to that
idea I think or even AI itself would
by its very nature would be observing us
by you know it's like uh human there
used to be this concept of human
computation which is actually exactly
what's feeding the current chat uh
language models which is leveraging all
the busy stuff we're doing
to do the hard work of learning so like
uh the language models are trained on
human
interaction in human language on the
internet and so it would AI feeds on the
output of brain power from humans and so
like it would be observing and observing
and it gets stronger as it observes so
it actually gets extremely good at
observing humans and one of the
interesting philosophical questions that
starts
percolating is what makes us what is the
interesting thing that makes us human
we tend to think of it uh and you said
like there's three phases what's the
thing that's hard to come by in phase
three
is it something like scarcity which is
limited resources is it something like
Consciousness is that the thing that's
very what
um that emerged The evolutionary process
in biological systems that are operating
under constrained resources
this thing that feels that it feels like
something to experience the world which
we think of as Consciousness is that
really difficult to replicate is in in
artificial systems is that the thing
that makes it fundamentally human
or is it just a side effect
that we attribute way too much
importance to Would You Do you have do
you have a sense
if you look out into the future and AI
systems are the ones that are traveling
out there
and to Alpha Centauri and Beyond
do you think they have to carry the the
flame of Consciousness with them
no not necessarily
um they may do but they may it may not
be
unnecessarily
I mean this I guess we're talking about
the difference here between sort of an
AGI artificial general intelligence or
Consciousness which are distinct ideas
and you can certainly have one without
the other so I couldn't imagine I would
I would disagree with this certainly in
that statement okay okay I I think it's
very possible in order to have
intelligence you have to have
consciousness
okay well I mean to a certain degree
chat gbt3 has a level of intelligence
already it's not a general intelligence
but it displays properties of
intelligence with with no consciousness
so again I would disagree okay okay well
I I don't I don't I don't know because
you said it's very nasty you said it
displays properties of intelligence in
the same way displaced properties of
intelligence I would say it's starting
to display properties of Consciousness
it certainly could fool you that it's
conscious
correct yes there's I guess like a a
Turing test problem like if it's
displaying all those properties
if it cracks like a parrot looks like a
parent or corrects like a duck things
like isn't it basically a duck at that
point so yeah I can see that argument
um it probably
it I mean certainly isn't it I try to
think about it from the observer's point
of view as an astronomer what am I
looking for whether that intelligence is
conscious or not has little bearing I
think as to what I should be looking for
when I'm trying to detect evidence of
them
it would maybe affect their behavior in
ways that I can't predict
um but that's again getting into the
game of what I would cause you know
psychology of trying to make projections
about the motivations of an alien
species is incredibly difficult
and simile for any kind of artificial
intelligence it's unfathomable what its
intentions may be I mean I would sort of
question whether it would even be
interested in traveling between the
stars at all
if its primary goal is computation
computation for the sake of computation
then it's probably going to have a
different
way of you know it's going to be
engineering its solar system and the
nearby material around it for for a
different goal if it's just simply
trying to increase computer substrate
Across the Universe
and that of course if that is its
principal intention to just essentially
convert dumb matter into smart matter as
it goes then
I think that would come into conflict
with our observations of the universe
right because
the the Earth shouldn't be here if that
were true the Earth should have been
transformed into computer substrate by
this point there has been plenty of time
yeah in the history of the Galaxy for
that to have happened
um so I'm skeptical
that we can uh
I'm skeptical in the part that that's a
behavior that AI or any civilization
really engages in but I also find it
difficult to find a way out of it
to explain why that would never happen
in the entire history of the Galaxy
amongst potentially if life is common
Millions maybe even billions of instant
instantiations of AI could have occurred
across the Galaxy
um and so that seems to be a knock
against the idea that there is life else
or intelligent life elsewhere in the in
the Galaxy the fact that that hasn't
occurred in our history is maybe the
only solid data point we really have
about the activities of other
civilizations
of course the scary one could be that um
we just at this stage intelligent alien
civilization just started destroying
themselves
hey because it becomes too powerful
everything's just too many weapons too
many nuclear weapons too many nuclear
weapons style systems that just
from mistake to aggression to like the
probability of self-destruction is too
high relative to the challenge of of
avoiding
the technological challenges of avoiding
self-destruction
you mean the the AI destroys itself or
no prior to the Advent of AI as we give
a smarter and smarter AI
um either AI destroys us or other there
could be just a million like AI is
correlated the development of AI is
correlated with all these other
technological innovation uh genetic
genetic engineering like all kinds of
engineering at the nanoscale
it's a mass manufacturer of things that
could destroy us or cracking physics
enough to have very powerful weapons
nuclear weapons all of it just too much
physics enables way too many things that
can destroy us
before it enables the um
the propulsion systems that allow us to
fly far enough away before we destroy
ourselves so maybe that's what happens
to the other alien civilization is that
your resolution because I mean I think
Us in the Techno signature community in
the astronomy Community aren't thinking
about this problem seriously enough in
my opinion we should we should be
thinking about the what AI is is doing
to our society and the implications of
what we're looking for and so the only I
think part of this thinking has to
involve people like yourself who are
more intimate with the machine learning
and artificial intelligence world is
your how do you reconcile in your mind
you said earlier that you think you
can't imagine a Galaxy where life and
intelligence is not all over the place
and if artificial intelligence is a
natural progression for civilizations
how do you reconcile that with
with the absence of any information
around us or any clues or hints of
artificial Behavior artificially
engineered stars or colonization
computer substrate transformed planets
anything like that it's it's uh
extremely difficult for me it's the the
Fermi Paradox broadly defined as
extremely difficult for me and the the
terrifying thing is one thing I suspect
is that we keep destroying ourselves the
probability of self-destruction with
with advanced technology is just
extremely high that's why we're not
seeing it
but then again my intuition about about
why we haven't blown ourselves up with
nuclear weapons
it it's very surprising to me from a
scientific perspective
but yeah it doesn't given all the
cruelty I've seen in the world
um given the the the the power that
nuclear weapons place in the hands a
very small number of individuals
it's very surprising to destroy
ourselves and it seems to be a very low
probability situation with Happening
Here
um
but and then the other explanation is
the is the zoo is the observation that
we're just being observed
that's that's the only other thing it's
just it's so difficult for me
of course all of science everything is
very humbling it would be very humbling
for me to learn
that we're alone in the universe
it would change
uh I you know what it maybe I do want
that to be true because you want us to
be special that's why I'm resisting that
thought maybe there's no way we're that
special there's no way we're that
special that's that's that's where my
resistance comes from I would just say
you know
the specialness is something we we in
implicitly in that statement there's
kind of an assumption that we are
something positive like we're a gift to
this planet or something and that makes
it special but you know it may be that
intelligence is more often is like we
like rats or cockroaches we're an
infestation of this planet and we're not
we're not some benevolent property that
the planet would apply would ideally
like to if they have if you can even say
such a thing but we we may be not only a
generally a negative Force for a plant's
biosphere and its own survivability
which I think you can make a strong
argument about but we may also be a very
persistent infestation that may even in
you know interesting thoughts in this in
the wake of a nuclear war
would that be an absolute eradication of
every human being which would be a
fairly extreme event or would the kind
of like Consciousness as you might call
it the flame of Consciousness continue
with some small Pockets that would maybe
in ten thousand years a hundred thousand
years we'd see civilization re-emerge
and play out the same thing over again
yeah that certainly the nuclear weapons
aren't powerful enough yet but yes the
uh but to sort of push back on the
infestation sure but the word special
doesn't have to be positive
I just mean
I think it tends to imply but yeah take
your point yeah but maybe
um
just maybe extremely rare maybe yeah
yeah and that to me it just it's very
strange
for me to be
cosmically unique it's just very strange
I I
mean that word the only thing
of this level of complexity in the
Galaxy just seems very strange to me I
would just yeah I I said I do think it
depends on this classification I think
there is sort of again it's kind of
buried within there as a subtext but
there was a a classification that we're
doing here that what we are is a
distinct category of of life let's say
in this case when we talk about
intelligence we have something that can
be separated
um but of course we see intelligence
across the Animal Kingdom in you know
Dolphins humpback whales
um octopuses crows Ravens and so it's
quite possible that
um
that these are all manifestations of the
same thing and we are not uh we are not
a particularly distinct class except for
the fact we make technology that's
really any difference to our
intelligence and we we classify that
separately but from a biological
perspective to some degree it's really
just all part of a Continuum and so
that's why I
when we talk about unique you're you're
you are putting yourself in a box which
is distinct and saying this is the only
example of things that fall into this
box but that but the walls of that box
May themselves be a construct of our own
arrogance that we are something distinct
and uh but I was also speaking broadly
for us meaning all life on Earth
that but then it's possible that there's
all kinds of
living
ecosystems in on other planets and other
moons that just don't have interest in
technological development and maybe
maybe technological development is the
the
parasitic thing it destroys the organism
broadly and then
maybe that's actually one of the
fundamental realities whatever broad way
to categorize technological development
that's that's just a parasitic thing
that just destroys itself